a certificate and books salvaged from
flood waters spread under the sun to dry
classrooms turned into kitchens
many of the people now in this school
have unfamiliar faces
and the regulars are worried about their
studies
like this student Muhammad zakariah
who's been joined by his displaced
family
nobody will
tell us to read there is no school so
our study may be
then maybe damaged
devastating floods this year have killed
hundreds of people in Nigeria and
displays hundreds of thousands
much infrastructure including school
buildings has been damaged
the few standing schools have become
shelters for people affected by the
disaster and students are no longer
coming to study but to shelter with
family members the United Nations
Children's Fund sells an estimated 18
and a half million children aren't
attending school in Nigeria at the
moment many of them due to floods and
other disasters as well as conflicts in
some States government officials are
waiting for flood waters to recede
before the reclaimed schools occupied by
the flood victims
but with entire Villages underwater no
one knows how long that will take in
other states education is priority we
are trying to provide an e-learning
facilities we have done that and we are
still trying to replicate see him now so
as that the students that are in the car
are displaced and it is even at the camp
they can be able to take lessons and
this has happened with we did during
covet and these facilities they can also
work offline
a plan of action but one that faces
challenges in a country struggling with
power shortages
it could be months or even a year before
people like these return to What's Left
of their homes
the schools they leave behind will have
to be fixed before teaching and learning
go start again
but government officials say there's
little money available
and no one seems to know whether these
facilities will ever get the work and
renovation they need Ahmad Idris
al-jizira Northern Nigeria